oh yeah yeah well I'm pretty sure your
mother's done something she's not proud
of either yeah yeah
all right good game man talk to you
later ah hello there today I'd like to
talk to you about the call of duty ghost
season pass now you've had needing three
months to conquer the campaign memorize
every multiplayer map and crack every
Easter egg that extinction has to offer
so that means two things one you clearly
like this game a lot and two you're
ready for something new which is great
because for DLC packs are coming to xbox
live DLC obviously stands for
downloadable content but it could just
as easily stand for delicious layer cake
his ghosts a delicious Victoria sponge
base mmm but what's better than cake
more cake and that's practically what
each DLC pack is another tasty layer
that builds on the foundations of your
ghost cake to create an all-powerful
mega cake now that is a thing of beauty
so you could buy each one of these
layers one by one or you could buy a
season pass and that would entitle you
to the full Quinn to Palayam mega cake
and an extra little bonus all at a much
lower price but only one DLC packs being
revealed so far why should i buy a
season pass before I even know what's in
them good question
okay so this is the first DLC pack it's
called onslaught and with good reason to
the four new multiplayer maps fog
bayview containment and ignition are all
small to medium sized arenas which means
you have four more environments that
offer the same sort of relentless
fast-paced skirmishes as fan favorites
like Warhawk freight and octane each new
map also offers a completely unique
field order bonus my personal favorite
being fog which actually lets you run
around as an axe wielding Michael Myers
and that's Michael Myers the Halloween
villain not the Austin Powers guy
although that would be good too on top
of that you'll get the Maverick a new
assault rifle that can transform into a
sniper rifle with a nifty digital sight
that makes you feel a bit like a cyborg
assassins in the future finally there's
nightfall the first of four new episodes
in the extinction saga this snow band
installment features new alien types
including the massive breeder and
with the seaweed for ceramic so to
answer your question with a question
do you fancy getting access to roughly
four times that amount of content and
the exclusive team leader digital pack
then you should probably invest in a
season pass because that's exactly what
you'll get of course there's more to it
than that the season pass represents a
saving of more than ten pounds versus
buying each pack individually which you
can then spend on actual cake or just
stuff under your mattress well oh yeah
the initials of each DLC pack spells out
the name Odin so if you buy the season
pass you're entitled to visit the Norse
God in his home of Asgard I've already
picked up mine and I'm booked in to see
him right now in fact see you later